another week in America another black
man killed by the police
Keith Lamont Scott was killed in
Charlotte North Carolina just four days
after Terrence crusher was shot dead in
Tulsa Oklahoma this came a week after 13
year old Tyree King was killed in
Columbus Ohio these deaths have become
commonplace in the u.s. so what's it
going to take to change the whole damn
system once and for all
here are three practical steps that can
be taken right now training in the
police academy differs from state to
state but according to the Bureau of
Justice on average it's less than six
months you can become a cop in six
months and don't have to have the same
amount of training as a cosmetologist
and it's less experienced younger cops
who are involved in many of the
shootings Darren Wilson the officer who
shot and killed 18 year old Michael
Brown was 28
Timothy Lowell men who killed 12 year
old Tamir rice was 26 but it's beyond
how long new recruits are getting
trained it's about what that training
includes is it humanizing or
dehumanizing civilians
step2 demilitarization police
departments across the country have
received military-style training along
with tanks assault rifles and high-tech
surveillance technology essentially
Pentagon leftovers
and giving police officers these weapons
may create an environment where
civilians are treated as the enemy a
federal ban was put in place back in May
2015 that would prohibit the further
transfer of certain militarized
equipment to local police departments
but after the latest wave of police
officer deaths several law enforcement
officials are now urging the White House
to lift the ban and ultimately fighting
police brutality is about accountability
more often than not the law sides with
police who use lethal force
when 25 year old Freddie gray died after
riding unsecured in a police wagon a
state medical examiner ruled his death a
homicide
but all charges against the officers
involved were dropped 43 year-old Eric
garner died when officer Daniel Pantaleo
placed him in a banned chokehold pencil
AO wasn't indicted either he's been on
desk duty and even received a 20% pay
increase over the last two years so what
does accountability look like well how
about more independent oversight
committees that not only hold officers
and departments accountable but also
help put together a national database on
police violence which by the way doesn't
even exist
so how many more deaths will it take for
meaningful reform to finally happen